We teamed up with a handful of the world's leading video scientists...
...and created something really awesome.
We call it "Cinema".
Cinematic stabilization for your videos...
...that will change video forever.
Let me show you what I mean.
This is us recording our video in the park.
This is the normal video, and this is Cinema.
Gorgeous, stabilized video for your iPhone.
Go!
This is the original.
Faster.
And this is with Instagram.
It's completely mind-blowing.
When you're running, chasing your kid, trying to get a beautiful video,...
...now, you have the power of Cinema in your pocket.
This changes everything.
And I'm excited to bring you Cinema.
Today, video on Instagram available for iOS and Android,...
...15 seconds of beautiful video,...
...13 custom filters.
Select a cover frame to show the world what you recorded.
And groundbreaking technology for video...
...that changes video forever and makes your video beautiful.
Cinema.